I was there I was there when a man
ripped through five steel doors and
torment in half with his bare hands I
was there when horrible things are up
today plane in mid-flight and set the
sane world ablaze I was there when the
Green made the Dead dance and scream I
was there when the orders came through
when those orders were carried out and
when they told us they needed to be
carried out once a day every day for the
rest of her life I was there when the
two best men I had ever known crumpled
in an instant because they looked away
and I stood there staring into that
ridiculous face that absurd ridiculous
face that was the last time anything
ever surprised me when I woke up at an
infirmary bed to be told that I had been
promoted I wasn't surprised when they
told me that they had falsified my death
and administered amnestics to the people
who knew better I wasn't surprised when
they brought me to command and I met the
others I wasn't surprised then they told
me that as part of the o5 orientation
they were going to explain to me what
SCP 0 0 1 was I wasn't surprised when I
met the rest of the council they told me
as per protocol I would be given an
introductory letter from the
administrator when I asked them where
the administrator was they simply told
me we don't know I almost laughed then
they owned five know everything
they handed me the letter and left the
room when I asked why they were leaving
they said for privacy I merely blinked
at him at this point I wondered whether
the whole thing was a joke so I sat down
in the chair they left for me and opened
the piece of paper welcomed newly
appointed overseer you have questions
perhaps you don't even know what they
all are
or care what the answers are this point
but you have them and you have many if
you open this letter expecting those
answers I will tell you all that I have
which is none what is as CP 0 0 1 there
isn't one
was there a first anomalous object that
was discovered of ours was it important
probably not confused good at least
you're still human that's all we are
human beings human beings that thought
we could reliably record the destruction
of sanity we were fools we still are the
foundation is compromised it always has
been and it always will be
why we thought there was a lynchpin a
reason for it all it's because we
thought there was a why
there wasn't one this is the way things
are nothing has changed
the universe hasn't broken down over
time this is how it is supposed to be
personnel are told about SCP 0 0 1
because it comforts them it helps to
think there is a why because that
suggests that there is a solution but
there isn't we do not repair we secure
contained protect surely you must have
wondered what the objects are not
numbered chronologically in order of
recovery surely you must have wondered
why some objects have fully documented
histories and others don't
surely you must have wondered given
everything you know why this world even
still exists see I told you that you had
more questions than you thought we don't
know how much of what we document it is
true anymore and it probably changes
from daily today there's no way of
telling what is being affected by what
anomaly especially when there could be
an infinite number that we haven't even
discovered existence is an anomaly so
what do we expect you to do armed with
this information or lack thereof
whatever you can we do not repair and we
do not solve we secure we contain we
protect congratulations on your
promotion to overseer good luck the
administrator I was there when not
caring was not good enough to protect me
from the truth I must have sat for an
hour before they came back for me when
they asked how I was all I said was a
little surprised they looked at me and I
heard the voice faintly welcome to
overwatch Brian the rest is history if
such a thing exists there is one more
thing though the letter had a PS don't
worry about it too much whatever you
think is the truth is probably good
enough anyway